Hi there, it's Marianne here. Before we dive into today's episode, I want to quickly let you know about something exciting that's happening right now. If you've ever wondered how to create income that works for you, rather than constantly trading your time for money, then you'll love the Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge with my business mentor, Lisa Johnson. This challenge is designed to help you build sustainable income streams. And whether you're an aspiring psychologist, a mental health professional, or in a completely different field,
the principles can work for you. There are also wonderful prizes to be won directly by Lisa herself. And if you join the challenge by my link, you can be in with a chance of winning a one-to-one hours coaching with me, Dr. Marianne Trent. Do you want to know more? Of course you do. Head to my link tree, Dr. Marianne Trent, or check out my social media channels, or send me a quick DM and I'll get you all the details. Right, let's get on with today's episode. If you're looking to become a psychologist, then let this be your guide. episode. with Dr. Marianne Trent.
Hi, welcome along to the Aspiring Psychologist podcast. I am Dr. Marianne Trent and thank you for listening or if you're on YouTube, thank you for watching. So today is episode 44 and it was supposed to be episode 43 which would have been rather magic except for life doesn't always run smoothly. So why it would have been super duper magic to have today be episode 43 is because the Aspiring Psychologist Collective book is now available. And that includes 43 individual personal accounts and reflections from aspiring psychologists. So it's like it was like meant to be. It would have been a happy accident. But actually, we do have more than 43 accounts in there because one of the contributors asked loads of people in her department to also write little snippet accounts and top tips and advice as well. So we've got loads more than 43 in there. But yes, a new baby has been born, the Aspiring Psychologist Collective. And I'm so excited and so pleased that it's been here.
And it's not been an easy process. So if you are watching on YouTube, you might be like, Marianne looks a bit rough today. I've got a horrid old cold. I was definitely squeezing my schedule more than I usually would, which meant less sleep, less kind of, less recharge time and I think as a result my children's lurgies which always kind of float around the edge having young children have finally come and snaffled me so I would hope that I'm on the way, on the way up out of it now but I said that as I said that I like a little bit of a sneeze in the back of my nose um I'm hoping I'm well and truly on the mend and by tomorrow I can be my usual perky slightly irritating myself um yeah so I've cancelled personal training this week just because I think
that's maybe not the the kindest thing I could be doing to myself when I'm not feeling well. So a bit of rest and recharge, some time to record podcasts and edit podcasts and look after myself. So let me tell you a little bit about this wonderful book and the people within it. So if you've previously caught the Clinical Psychologist Collective book and you enjoyed it, then I'm going to say 100% guaranteed that you are going to also enjoy the Aspiring Psychologist Collective. If you've never heard of either, then I'll just give you a little bit of background about what the books are and specifically what this new book is. So both books, in fact, the Grief Collective book as well, are what's called autoethnography. So they are people's words, reflective accounts, talking about their own life experiences and kind of things they've experienced along the way.
They are wonderful to read if you're looking to improve your own skills as an aspiring psychologist in reflection and in kind of thinking about your own story and how you've grown over time. They're also really, really good for giving you ideas about how you could, you know, approach your career in a way that might help you get your foot in the door or, you know, get where you want to be or have ideas about jobs or roles to apply for. So that's certainly feedback that I've had about things that people have really enjoyed about the clinical psychologist collective book but I recognized that getting on training you know when you read the clinical psychologist collective getting on training feels like it's then inevitable because even though it was tricky you know everybody managed it and so I wanted to just introduce you to a stage before
that so within the aspiring psychologist collective spoiler alert there are some trainings or now trainings that probably weren't trainings when they wrote their accounts because they got on to training during this most recent season. But there are also people who are yet to apply for professional psychology routes. There are also people who did apply and weren't successful and kind of found out quite close to the wire that they weren't being offered places. And so it's kind of like a roller coaster real life ride through professional psychology not just clinical psychology but I would say probably 95% is clinical psychology so there's some PhD in there and some educational psychology I don't think we've got any counselling or forensic that I can think about I feel like I know the stories quite well and I don't think
we've got that um in in the stories um unless it's one of the ones that was submitted quite early and I therefore signed off on a long time ago so i'm sorry if you're listening to this and you're like i am i made it and she didn't mention me i'm really sorry but trying to juggle 43 stories as well as all of the publishing demands um has been tricky um but yeah so grateful for everybody who is within the aspiring psychologist collective and they will all be getting a contributor copy as well but you can now grab your copy there's a link in the show notes for how to do that um and it is via amazon but um yeah check the show notes or check um any details on my my social media for a direct link to the right book.
So let's have a little bit of a think about some of the themes in the book. So one of the themes is most definitely self-care and reducing burnout. And also with a lovely sprinkling of compassion in there too we've got a foreword in this book for the first time ever by Dr Chris Irons who's also a clinical psychologist and writes lots of lovely books on self-compassion and compassion focused therapy and the benefits for ourselves and our clients about introducing that into our world so thank you very much Chris I will be sending you a copy to say a big thank you as well but yeah the idea of other aspiring psychologists almost talking to you in many cases in their accounts about how to remain compassionate to
yourself and how to not burn out on the way to where you want to be is absolutely running throughout the stories within all of the collective I would say. It kind of feels like soul food for psychologists, I think. It's not your average book. It's not a textbook. It's just a really nice connected experience where you feel like part of the process and you're rooting for people in their own journeys as well. So that's theme one, I would say. Theme two is that people have been really honest about their own impact and their own mental health journeys along the way, either as a result of kind of stresses and strains of the job, or due to kind of non-job related things as well so I know often I get asked questions you know should I disclose about any mental health history that I've had and this
kind of book will give you really useful insights for how people are thinking about it and talking about it and how they're actually you know quite proud about their experiences in the sense they've made of it and how, in fact, all of this reflecting and all of this growth and change and, you know, difficulties they've had along the way makes them a better psychologist and not a worse one. So if you're looking for top tips about how to think about that for your own professional psychology career, then I'd say this book is going to be especially wonderful for you too. If you've been listening to the podcast for a while, you will know that I love a jingle. So it's no surprise that I also have a jingle for the new book, baby. So let you be the very first people to hear it. And I will catch up with you on the other side of that.
I hope you enjoy it. So many tips and lessons to learn from. So many things that you can try. The Aspiring Psychologist Collective. The Aspiring Psychologist Collective. oh my days if you didn't find that rousing are you even breathing um you know oh jingle guy you're just so talented like oh just love it. The first version of that was also marvellous. But I was like, Paul, because that's his name. I love it. And I love Christmas as much as the next person. And I love sleigh bells. But I think the sleigh bells might make it sound a little bit too Christmassy. And this book, this book, baby, is a book bit too christmasy and this book this book baby
is a book for all seasons it's not just a book for the winter christmas season so could we maybe not have the christmasy one but maybe i should do the christmasy one around christmas so you can hear this sleigh bell version so perhaps I've ended up getting two jingles for the price of one I'll have to give you a bit more money Paul um but yeah I love that like I just imagine you in your kitchens or your showers or out walking your dogs like just yeah being uplifted and you know energized so energized. So yeah, I really like that. The Clinical Psychologist Collective book is a bit more mellow-y, isn't it? But this one is like, yeah, guys, we've got it. We are on it. We are on this mission. So yeah, absolutely thrilled with that and hope you like
it. Feedback about Jingles is gratefully received. You may have noticed there's no audio testimonials yet because this book baby is so brand new that we don't have any. However, however, there is your chance to feature in audio testimonials but also help yourself at the same time. So there's going to be information in the show notes about how you, yes, you can leave me an audio testimonial. So what is going to be happening is we've got a little competition running until midnight on Halloween 2022. so the 31st of October 2022. So as not to exclude people that have bought the Clinical Psychologist Collective book recently, if you have bought either book between the 1st of September and then midnight 31st of October 2022. And you send me your unique proof of purchase.
So please don't use someone else's. Your unique proof of purchase for either or both books. You can get an entry to win a one-to-one coaching session with me. And the coaching sessions will be happening on the first, second or third of November. So if you can't do that day, you might want to think about perhaps not entering, but we could do daytime or we could do evening one of those days. So yeah, you can get your chance to then talk with me about your psychology career and if you've got a professional psychology application we can use that time together to go through that together to think about really strengthening it and making it have more bang for your buck but if you're not applying this year
we can use that session to really think about professional skills and, you know, your next step. Or if you're qualified already and you'd welcome using that session for, you know, professional coaching, for thinking about your way forward for stuff that might not just be one-to-one therapy, then please do submit your proof of purchase as well. But because we were speaking about audio testimonials, you can also get a bonus point by recording me an audio testimonial for either book. And there's a way you can do that that I will drop in the show notes and also pop out with my socials as well. Yes, because it's great to be able to demonstrate real readers and what they think to the book. So please do take a moment to do that.
And when you submit your testimonial, if it's usable, no swearing in it, and it's audible, etc. Then I will give you a bonus point, a bonus entry into that prize draw. And if you want to do one for both books, you can get two bonus entries. And then last but not least, if you leave me a verified purchase review for either or both books, you can also get bonus points, bonus entries. So here's your chance to get one, two, three, four, five, potentially six entries to get a one to one with me. If you only wanted one book, then you can just do that related to one book. But if you've already read the Clinical Psychologist Collective and would like to leave me a testimonial for that, please do that as well.
Because it's really lovely to be able to demonstrate. People love it, you know, people are really, really benefiting from the content within that. So yes, please do, please do do that. All right. So let's get back on to some of the themes for the new book, the Aspiring Psychologist Collective. Just looking at my list there, because I did write myself a little prompt list this time, because I do usually freestyle for these episodes, but the old brains aren't working so well right now,
because they're just being a bit sleep deprived and a little bit muggy headed. OK, so another theme which has developed really wonderfully within the APC, as we've been calling it when we've been publishing, the Aspiring Psychologist Collective, is that people are offering their top tips to you throughout, you know. And that's just really really great um you know ways that you can think oh yeah I could totally do that um that's a bit of me you know I yeah that really resonates with me so um yeah dive on in and discover those top tips for yourself and when I was growing up, I was always taught, we mustn't draw in books, Marianne. It's very bad, very bad behavior. But there are some books that
I have bent the rules for over my time. And I've got highlighters out and, you know, I've added little sticky memos to pages that I knew I'd want to come back for and I would definitely say that this book the aspiring psychologist collective is a kind of book that you can bend the rules for you can get your highlighters out and you can stick stickers in and help this be really bespoke to you and you can write in it bits that resonate with you or spark ideas so this becomes almost your own personal reflections as well as that of that of the contributors as well and another theme is collaboration it really feels like a collaborative effort I know when I was an aspiring psychologist it very much felt like it was each man or each woman for themselves.
And I think that it feels different to that these days. It feels like people really want you to succeed as well. They don't want to keep all these secrets to themselves. And by the very nature of all of the free content I've been producing with this podcast, with the Q&As and with the feedback that I've been getting with this podcast, with the Q&As, and with the feedback that I've been getting from people as well, is just how refreshing it is to have this content put out there by a qualified psychologist, someone that's giving such useful, tangible, actionable advice, and, you know, is demonstrating this stuff is working you know it's working for people within my world it's working for people people are watching the q a's
they're trying my tips and then they're messaging me to say oh that was really helpful that really worked i really got some good stuff there um so please um if you're enjoying what I'm doing do consider leaving me a review on Apple podcasts would be wonderful so if you click on library which is at the bottom of your podcast app and then click on shows and hopefully you're following me already and then click on the aspiring psychologist collective and then scroll down a little bit where it says episodes and then currently the bottom of episode 36 but it would depend when you're watching this is one that says trailer and then below trailer we've got ratings and reviews so if you've got just one moment just click hopefully Hopefully a five star review would be great. But if you've got a little while longer, just click the see all. You can't really see. Click the see all next to ratings and reviews.
And then the option there is write a review. So that would be really, really wonderful. I've had one most recently given me today. not today, Tuesday. So I haven't seen this one yet. So this is breaking news. Let me read this to you. Thank you, Marianne, for sharing and recording these podcasts. They're an excellent resource full of helpful, compassionate and insightful experiences and reflections, which are useful when we're navigating the twisty world of clinical psychology. These topics are core to working in the field of psychology and highlight the importance of self-compassion along your journey in and outside of psychology. I love that. Thank you so much. So, yes, the ratings and reviews really help us to demonstrate that what we're doing is useful.
And then when shows have more ratings and reviews they get shown more readily to other people so they help us further that collaborative nature so you know if you don't want to buy anything if you don't want to leave me any reviews please at least follow or subscribe because that helps me know that you are valuing what you're getting from us. So, yeah, the themes of the book are just wonderful. And this time we have pictures and things in the book as well. So not photographs as such, but just different kind of infographics, different things to read just to break up the text a bit and to kind of um yeah help you yeah
help it feel like a really nice read um and it's yet to be finalized but the plan is um the the hardback is going to be available in full color as well um it was on my to-do list um to get that sorted um but i don't feel very well um so this week has been a little bit different than what was expected um but there yes within the book there is also an exclusive download for you um for thinking about how to um really understand the declensi um application season um giving you top tips as well. So, yeah, grab your copy. Come on in. Don't forget about that contest, that competition, which is closing midnight on Halloween, 31st of October.
Please do come along and join us in the Facebook group as well, which is the Aspiring Psychologist Collective. That group is building nicely. We only launched that probably a month or so ago um but yeah come on over be part of my world also please let me know what you like next what would be useful for you in the podcast um i aim for this to be really useful stuff for you so yes um it's it's here it's my next book baby and it's the one that I think I am proudest of yet um just because it's really lovely really lovely and I think it's that that's me on the back on a good good day. It's that collaborative nature, which feels so useful. And I think because if you're reading this as an aspiring psychologist or an aspiring mental health professional, it's just going to be talking to you where you're at right
now. And so it's going to be wonderfully validating and normalizing and nourishing so I hope you really enjoy it I can't wait and also I'm a little bit nervous to see what people think of it I hope that you really like it as much as I do and as much as my proofreader has done as well be kind and yeah let me know what you think but yes until then until i hear from you um i will look forward to catching up with you on our next episode which is going to be landing with you 6 a.m on monday um but yeah thank you very much enjoy this exit jingle um and yeah if you want to listen back to the rousing aspiring psychologist collective jingle
um please do um but yeah catch up with you soon thank you so much for being part of my world bye if you're looking to become a psychologist then let this be your guide with this podcast at your side you'll be on your way to being qualified. It's the Aspiring Psychologist Podcast. With Dr. Marianne Duret. My name's Yana and I'm a trainee psychological wellbeing practitioner. I read the Clinical Psychologist Collective book. I found it really interesting about all the different stories and
how people got to become a clinical psychologist. It just amazed me how many different routes there are to get there and there's no perfect way to become one and this kind of filled me of confidence that no I'm not doing it wrong and put less pressure on myself so if you're feeling a bit uneasy about becoming a clinical psychologist I definitely recommend this just to put yourself at ease and everything will be okay but trust me you will not put the book down once you start There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.